[Music]
the i-team with more about the bar
involved in that bartender heist we told
you about just last night now a
bartender robbed at gunpoint says he was
forced to pay the stolen money back and
now we're learning the company involved
faced a class action lawsuit over wages
several years ago the i-team's david
charns here now with that part of the
story that a lot of people david are
talking about a lot of people talking
about this today guys after the i-team
showed you this video last night we told
you about edward parker's story he was
working that early morning shift at the
lodge at hualapai a year ago when a
gunman stormed in demanding cash
according to a lawsuit we first told you
about yesterday management at the lodge
made him pay the nearly 4 thousand
dollars back
having hundreds of dollars deducted from
each of his paychecks lodge settled a
separate class action suit in 2018 that
said it was paying bartenders below the
minimum wage required when health
insurance isn't offered it also said
bartenders weren't paid the right amount
in overtime now the attorney behind that
lawsuit christian gabroy commenting
today on this new lawsuit filed this
week to pay the man and then to be
insulted with that contract you're
talking about something like i said
something that belongs in the slavery
days with us i mean how how could any
individual how can an employer do that
to another human who's worked hard i
don't know i i don't know how they sleep
at night
well as part of that class action the
lodge agreed to a 217 thousand dollar
settlement about 130 employees were paid
on average 400 each now we reached back
out to the lodge again today we reached
out to them earlier this week for that
initial story and we have not heard back
i'm david sharon is live local now